Okay.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ayildiz und ich bin ab dieser Situation als Assistenzarztätik
und ich höre gerne mit Ihnen eine Medikamente überführen. Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache, ich klinge immer schon auch noch ein Mediaklar.
Okay, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiß Gerda Katz.
Gerne Katz. Können Sie die Reformnachnahme Busta Birgit?
Ja, beide kurz, zum Glück. Gerda Gerda-R-G-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-G-R-T-S-S-G.
Und Katz, wie die Katze?
Kataz
Okay, Frau Katz.
Mh hm?
Okay, Frau Katz. Wie persons Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre.
accepts
12.07.1969, Entschuldigung.
Kein Problem. Wie groß sind Sie?
1.68.
Okay, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Na, so um die 72 kg, mal ein bisschen mehr, mal ein bisschen weniger.
Katze, Katze, Frau Katze, wo sind die Tonz?
Welche Beschwerde haben Sie?
Ich habe schon so lange richtig dollen Husten und jetzt tut mir die ganze Brust so richtig weh.
Ich habe ganz starke Schmerzen und der Husten wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Nachts kann ich zurzeit auch gar nicht mehr schlafen.
Ich habe jetzt auch so und es tut richtig weh beim Husten und beim Einatmen.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie Brustchmerzen?
Ja, das hat eigentlich sofort 3, 4 Tagen angefangen.
Und da es jetzt überhaupt nicht besser geworden ist, habe ich gedacht, ich komme mal zu Ihnen.
Ich habe natürlich auch Medizin genommen.
Ich habe erstmal so Schleimlöser genommen und dann habe ich auch sogar so Kuddin-Tropfen gehabt.
Da hatte ich noch welche vor ein paar Jahren und das hat alles nicht geholfen.
Okay, wissen Sie, wie die Medikament heißt?
Oh nee, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Okay, kein Problem.
Seit wann haben die Husten?
Ja, das fing so vor einer Woche ungefähr an, aber es wird eben immer schlimmer.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen noch ein bisschen aushalten oder sollte ich Ihnen die Schmerzen geben?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie gesagt, ich habe die ja jetzt schon ein paar Tage, aber es ist halt so,
dass man halt nicht ewig mit solchen Schmerzen rumlaufen will.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie schwitzen haben.
Hab ich Sie verstanden?
Das ich was?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie schwitzen haben.
Ich schwitze?
Ja, ich habe in der Nacht schwitze ich immer so doll, ja.
Okay, und können Sie bitte die Schmerzen beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen erhördummt oder stechend?
Das stechend nicht, vielleicht so drückend und ja, manchmal brennt das auch richtig in der Lunge.
Sind die Schmerzen abhängig, die ausatmen oder einatmen?
Also wenn ich ganz doll einatme, dann sind Sie richtig schlimm, ja.
Okay.
Deswegen atmen, das ist auch so komisch, man traut sich gar nicht mehr so richtig tief einzuatmen, weil es dann weh tut, ne?
Ja, okay. Sie haben höchsten.
Sie haben den höchsten Auswurf?
Ja, da kommt ein ganz fieses gelbes Zeug raus, ganz fies.
Wie sagt ihr auch?
Ja, gelb, gelber klein, ganz eklig.
Schöne, okay.
Okay, okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Ich glaube schon, ich fühle mich total heiß, ja.
Also gerade in der Nacht, wie gesagt, glücklich und heute morgen, aber ich habe mich tatsächlich gar nicht gemessen, habe ich vergessen, ja.
Aber ich fühle mich wirklich schon richtig fiebrig und krank, ja.
Okay, haben Sie außer Schleimlöter eine Schmerzmittel oder eine andere Medikamente ein?
Ja, also ich habe hier diesen Schleimlöter, das ist ja dieses ACC, das man immer so nimmt, aber dann habe ich noch die Codein-Tropfen genommen.
Aber sonst habe ich keine anderen Medikamente genommen.
Okay, haben Sie, leiden Sie an Herzstrasen, Herzkropfen, oder?
Also ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass das Herz ein bisschen mehr schlägt, ja, mehr als sonst, ja.
Okay, ist Ihnen schwindelig oder schwarf oder aufgefallen?
Nein, nein, also, was nicht, nee.
Okay, Sie haben Brustschmerzen, Strahlen und Schmerzen, irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, nein, das ist nur so, halt so beim Atmen und beim Husten, dass es da halt so weh tut. Aber das strahlt nicht aus, nein.
Okay, und Sie haben aus höchstem Mietausruf und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, also ich wieg mich jetzt nicht jeden Tag, aber ich habe eigentlich nicht abgenommen in letzter Zeit, nee.
Okay, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen oder Halsschmerzen?
Ja, so am Anfang, bevor das mit dem Husten losging, hatte ich so ein bisschen Halsschmerzen, wie halt immer so eine Erkältung sich anbahnt, ja.
Aber Kopfschmerzen, ja, so ein bisschen durch dieses Fiebergefühl, so ein bisschen Dröhnkopf, ja, aber also jetzt nicht schlimm.
Hatten Sie etwas, hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden für Herr gehabt?
Ja, ich hatte natürlich schon nichts mal in meinem Leben Husten gehabt, ja.
Okay.
Aber also, dass ich solche Schmerzen dabei hatte und das es mir so schlecht ging, das kenne ich nicht.
Okay, für Herr Herr und ich habe noch einige Fragen über allgemeine Gesundheit, diese Zustand und wie ist Ihr Appatit?
Im Augenblick ist er natürlich nicht so doll normal, kann nicht ganz gut essen und ich muss halt so auch ein bisschen aufpassen mit dem Essen,
weil ich so einen, ja, hat man festgestellt so diesen Alterszucker hab und da darf man ja jetzt nicht nur unbegrenzt essen,
sondern muss halt auch ein bisschen ach geben, aber eigentlich ist mein Appetit schon gut, ja, aber jetzt zur Zeit schmeckt es mir nicht, nee.
Okay.
Und Sie haben Husten, Ihre Husten, ist Ihre Husten, attackartig oder tagsüber leiden Sie an?
Husten, unterhusten.
Also nachts ist es besonders schlimm und tut es auch besonders weh und tagsüber habe ich auch immer wieder Husten, ich muss ständig Husten.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Also normalerweise habe ich da eigentlich keinen großen Problem, nee.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in Ihrem Auswurf Blut bemerkt?
Nee, das hätte ich gesehen, Brut war da nix, das ist nur so gelblich so.
Okay, na gelblich.
Okay.
Und, ja, Sie haben gesagt Alterszucker, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Alterszucker haben, haben Sie noch eine andere Kankung?
Ja, das, was wir alle so haben in meinem Alter, ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck so, ne.
Seit wann haben Sie Alterszucker und Blutdruck?
Ja, also mit dem Zucker, das hat man schon vor zehn Jahren testen gestellt, das hat eigentlich früh angefangen, ja.
Und dann nehme ich natürlich auch Medikamente, also dann nehme ich halt mit Formin regelmäßig.
Und mit dem Blutdruck, das hat man so vor fünf Jahren ungefähr, seitdem nehme ich Rami-Pril zweimal am Tag, einmal morgens und einmal abend.
Wie sind Sie mit welchem Dosier nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, ich meine Rami-Pril zehn, kann das sein? Ja, ich meine Rami-Pril zehn ist das.
Okay. Und Med-Formin mit welchem Dosier nehmen Sie?
Das sind tausende, und dann nehme ich halt eine am Morgen.
Okay, tausend, ein Morgen.
Frau Katz, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Muss ich wirklich überlegen, ob ich schon mal operiert worden bin? Kann mich gar nicht erinnern.
Ne, mein ganzes Leben.
Na ja, gut, als Kind natürlich habe ich die Mandeln rausbekommen, ja. Aber sonst bin ich noch nie operiert worden.
Okay, wie waren Sie, wie waren Sie alt?
Ich war als Kind, neun oder acht oder neun Jahre, also in dem Dreh.
Okay, als Kind. Und gab es in der Operation Probleme oder Komplikation?
Das ist ja schon so lange her, aber ich wüsste nicht, dass da irgendwas Schlimmes war.
Okay, Frau Katz, haben Sie alle Gehör- oder Umfeld-Erektik?
Nee, also nicht, dass ich wüsste, ich kann alles essen und trinken und was ich will.
Also da ist alles unaufwählig.
Alles unaufwählig. Okay, haben Sie Haustier, Frau Katz?
Nein, nein, also mal ein Hund oder Katze oder so, nee, nee, das habe ich nicht.
Sind Sie vorstellend geimpft gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten oder COVID-19?
Also COVID-19, da habe ich vier Impfungen mitgemacht und Kinderkrankheiten, das ist natürlich schon sehr lange her mit den Kinderkrankheiten.
Aber da bin ich eigentlich damals gegen, also so viel ich weiß, gegen alles gefährliche Geimpfte worden, ja.
Okay, sind Sie schon im nächsten Jahr?
Ja, das fängt so gerade an, aber noch habe ich so schleichend, aber nicht ganz regelmäßig meine Periode.
Okay, wann war die letzte Periode?
Das ist so drei Wochen her.
Drei Wochen her.
Und wenn Sie Ihre Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, sicher, klar.
Sehr gut.
Frau Katz, rauchen Sie?
Nee, also ich habe mein Leben noch nicht geraucht und deswegen finde ich so gemein, dass ich solchen Husten habe, ja.
Ich habe nie geraucht und ich habe so einen fiesen Husten.
Okay, und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ganz selten, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, wenn es ein gutes Essen gibt, mein Glas Wein dazu oder mein Schluck Sekt bei einer Feier oder so etwas, ja.
Aber also ganz selten, wirklich.
Und ich muss noch eine Frage über Genüschmitteil, aber ich muss fragen, bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nee, also Drogen, ja, nun wirklich nicht, nein.
Okay, ich grüttere Sie sehr gut, nicht gut im Konsum, irgendem Konsum, nicht bekannt.
Sehr gut.
Und ich habe einige Fragen über Familien an einem Nese.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch, Frau Katz?
Meine Mutter ist gestorben, die hatte Brustkrebs und die ist nicht sehr alt geworden.
Und mein Vater, der lebt zum Blutloch, der ist weitgehend gesund, der hat so ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, aber sonst ist er eigentlich erschreckend fit, ja.
Wie alt Ihr Vater?
Ja, der ist jetzt, warte mal, wie alt wird er? Der wird schon fast 90, ja.
89 oder so, nächstes Jahr wird er, glaube ich, 90, ja.
Herr Hesichenbeileid für Ihre Mutter, haben Sie gestorben?
Nee, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf, Frau Katz?
Ich arbeite im Finanzamt.
Sie arbeiten im Büro?
Ja, ich bin da angestellt.
Aber jetzt die Tage war ich nicht bei der Arbeit, also das ging überhaupt gar nicht.
Ich habe mich gerade gemeldet.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß, die Kinder, die sind nicht mehr bei uns im Haus.
Sie haben gesunde Kinder, wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei sind es.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Mann?
Ja, sicher, klar.
Waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Ja, im Sommerurlaub, warte mal, sind das sechs Monate, da waren wir mal in Dänemark,
aber sonst waren wir nicht im Ausland.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Katz, Sie haben, ich fasse kurz,
ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen,
und Sie haben seit einer Woche Husten
und seit drei, vier Tagen Brustschmerzen.
Ja.
Die Beschwerden sind mit der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Das kann man sagen, ja, wirklich.
Und Sie haben auch Schwitz, und Sie fühlen sich friedlich,
aber Sie haben nicht gemessen.
Und wegen Husten haben Sie auch Halsschmerzen.
Ja, Ihre Husten sind in der Nacht schlimmer geworden.
Ja, da kann ich ganz schnell schlafen, da hat man das Gefühl,
weil ich gar keine Luft kriege.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen geschwollene oder gerötete Beine aufgefallen?
Meine Beine, das ist mir nix aufgefallen, aber da habe ich auch nicht besonders drauf geachtet.
Okay.
Und Sie haben keinen Atemnot?
Ja, also wenn der Husten grad so ganz schlimm ist,
hat man schon so kurz das Gefühl, dass man keine Luft bekommt.
Das ist schon ein bisschen blöd, ja.
Ja, wenn der Husten überhaupt nicht aufhört,
dann ringt man schon ein bisschen nach Luft zwischendurch.
Ja, Frau Katz, jetzt wälte ich Sie körperlich und versuche,
dann etwas Blut abnehmen und einige andere Beine.
Und einige operative Maßnahmen durchführen, zum Beispiel Röntgen.
Was meinen Sie operative Maßnahmen? Was ist das?
Ja, ich werde Röntgen, Brustkorb durchführen.
Ah, okay, ja.
Und dann, wenn ich alle Ergebnisse gesammelt habe,
werde ich mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen und informiere Sie,
wie es sich schritt.
Haben Sie für mich Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt ja so viel erzählt.
Also, nee, Fragen habe ich jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich wüsste nicht, also Sie haben ja gerade gesagt,
jetzt weiter geht, also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich noch fragen könnte.
Was ist interessant, ob ich nachher nach Hause kann?
Ja, jetzt werde ich körperlich untersuchen und einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann erkläre ich Ihnen ganz genau.
Jetzt kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Können Sie das noch nicht sagen?
Okay, dann warten wir das halt ruhig ab.
Dankeschön.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte legen Sie.
Sehr gut.
Aber in der Zeit, ha, Scharf, ja.
Gut.
Wöchte jemand noch etwas fragen?
Darf ich?
Ja, klar.
Aufgrund der Beschwerden haben die schon beim
Ihrem Ja-Haus-Haus oder Krankenhaus anmelden, oder?
Nein, beim Haus als war ich nicht.
Wissen Sie, das ist ja gerade Karneval und da haben die alle Ferien.
Oder beim Krankenhaus oder anderen?
Nee, jetzt bin ich ja im Krankenhaus, jetzt bin ich aber Ihnen.
Aber vorher war ich noch nicht.
Darf ich?
Ja.
Wo ist jemand?
Ich höre nichts.
Irgendjemand wollte gerade noch fragen.
Hallo.
Ja, jetzt.
Ich habe es überhört.
Sie hat nicht gemessen, aber sie fühlt sich fieberig.
Hallo, darf ich etwas fragen?
Natürlich.
Leitet Ihre Vater an eine Krankheit, den Sie wissen?
Mein Vater, der ist ja, eigentlich ist er fit, aber er hat ein bisschen
hohen Blutdruck.
Eine kunstliche Krankheit oder so was.
Der hat nur ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, sonst ist er fit.
Okay, danke.
Darf ich?
Ja?
Prokatz, mir ist die Konsistenz des Auswurfs.
Ja, das ist so grünlicher, gelblich grünlicher Schlein.
So ein bisschen brockig.
Schon ein bisschen?
Brockig, so Schleinstückchen da drin.
Danke.
Ein paar Themen, die sich in Ihrem Umgebund befinden.
Meinen Sie im Büro oder in der Familie?
Nein, so ein Husten hat keiner außer mir.
Ein bisschen schnupfen und Husten haben ja alle Leute jetzt im Augenblick.
Aber so ein Husten wie jetzt hier bei mir, das hat sonst keiner.
Haben Sie das akustisch nicht verstanden?
Haben Sie vielleicht einen Coronatest gemacht?
Coronatest habe ich gemacht, als es angefangen hat.
Als es angefangen hat mit dem Husten, der habe ich einen gemacht,
ja, aber der war negativ.
Ich habe es nicht nochmal wiederholt nach ein paar Tagen.
Ich muss mal auch schon denken.
Waren Sie schon früher Stationär im Krankenhaus?
Nein, ja, als man es mit dem Zucker festgestellt hat, da bin ich mal stationär.
Ich habe es ein paar Tage da gewesen, weil man das erst richtig beobachten wollte.
Und dann ich diese chronische Husten angefangen oder bevor der zum Beispiel Krankenhaus,
ja, waren Sie in Krankenhausen?
Das ist schon lange hier mit dem Krankenhausaufenthalt.
Das ist jetzt nicht aus dem Krankenhaus.
Ich bin hier lange nicht in der Klinik gewesen.
Ist das Ihre Frage?
Ist die damit beantwortet?
Ja, ich möchte lernen, ob diese Beschwerden nach dem,
die ist aufenthalt im Krankenhaus angefangen oder bevor.
Nein, der Krankenhausaufenthalt liegt schon lange zurück.
Das ist jetzt nicht kürzlich gewesen.
Dr. Osman, Sie sagen, wenn es weitergehen kann.
Ich kann anfangen.
Guten Tag Frau Oberastin.
Ich habe eine neue Patiente aufgenommen.
Ich habe den Fall kurz vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Wie haben Sie gesehen?
Es geht um jeder Katz, die 56 Jahre Patiente.
Patientin?
Patientin.
Sie kamen zu uns heute seit einer Woche bestehende,
progradierte Husten und seit drei und vier Tagen progradierte
sie mit Brustschmerzen.
Ihre Hüste sei mit Auschubutum und geblich und schleimig.
Sie haben sich mit dem Atmen abhängig und mit dem Atmen verschlechtert.
Sie fühle sich fübrig, aber sie haben keine gemessen.
Sie haben auch nicht gemessen.
Sie klagten wegen der Hüste.
Sie haben auch Schmerzen, aber nicht genau.
Die Hüste seien in der Nacht verschlimmert.
Die geniäkologische Anämnese sei unaufregig.
Die letzte Präferatik war drei Wochen.
Vor drei Wochen?
Ja, vor drei Wochen.
Als Frau Erkrankungen gab sie an,
dass sie seit zehn Jahren an Diabetes meines Types war
und seit fünf Jahren an Arteriopetroni leide.
Bei ihr wurde die Tosilektomie als Kind durchgefüllt.
Sie nahmen regelmäßig mit Formen 1000 mg, morgens und Romipil seltenmig, morgens und abends ein.
Die Anämnese ist unaufregig und sie haben keine Haustiere.
Sie haben vorhin geimpft, auch COVID-19.
Sie trinken bei Feier, Engliswein oder Sekt.
Sie berichten, dass ihr Mutter an Mama Karlsnorm verstorben sei.
Sie haben vorhin geimpft, dass ihr Vater der 90-Jährige Leide an Arteriopetroni angestellt und verheiratet.
Sie haben zwei gesunde Kinder.
Sie sind unaufregig.
Das war es.
Was ist denn Ihre Vermutung?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Pynomani.
Was könnte sonst sein?
Ich würde die Patientin körperlich untersuchen und mit der Perimeter überprüfen.
Was würde das sein?
Ich würde Lungen abhören.
Ich warte auch, dass ich die Patientin körperlich untersuchen und mit der Perimeter überprüfen.
Ich würde gerne EKG verrennissen, um einige New Card-Impact or the Act Corner Syndrome auszuheben.
Ich würde etwas Blut abnehmen.
Sie haben die Patientin selbst befragt.
Worauf achten Sie noch?
Ich meine die Beinspellung, die Sie angesprochen haben.
Was wäre Ihre Diagnose?
Ich würde die Patientin nach Viter-Parameter ambulanter behandeln oder stationär aufnehmen.
Wenn Ihre Sauerstoff-Settingung erledigt ist, würde ich die stationär aufnehmen.
Was könnte die Analyse und Antibiotikum verschreiben?
Was könnte man labortechnisch noch weiter untersuchen, um die Patientin gezielt helfen zu können?
Ich komme jetzt zur Manöverkritik.
Ich finde Sie sprechen schwer verständlich.
Ich musste mich sehr konzentrieren, um Sie gut zu verstehen.
Sie haben schon noch ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten mit der deutschen Grammatik.
Sie sprechen nicht ganz fließend.
Wir konnten uns verständigen, aber es fordert vom Zuhörer eine starke Konzentration.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das in der Prüfung ankommt.
Ich wäre nicht so überrascht, weil die Düsseldorfer sind ja berühmt dafür, dass sie drittische Prüfer sind.
Ich würde sagen, dass man gar nichts diskutieren kann.
Sie haben alles wiedergegeben im Gespräch, was die Patientin gesagt hat.
Ich wüsste nicht, dass etwas unter Tisch gefallen ist.
Natürlich ist die Symptomatik ziemlich eindeutig bei dieser Patientin.
Sie haben sich sehr gut geschlagen und haben alles wiedergegeben.
So schnell werden wir nicht so viel ändern können.
Sie müssen mit Mut zur Lücke rein.
Sie sprechen mit den Prüfern, Patienten und fiktiven Oberarzt.
Sie sprechen freundlich mit dem, machen das Beste aus der Prüfung.
Wenn Rückfragen kommen, wiederholen Sie oder formulieren.
Sie haben immer mal wieder verschiedene Formulierungen für Ihre Fragen gemacht.
Sie haben aufgefallen und bemerkt, dass es gut ist.
Es ist nur ein Ausspracheproblem, das mich eingeschränkt hat.
Aber grobe Fehler haben wir nicht gefunden.
Wir können sehr zufrieden sein mit heute Abend.
Gehen Sie freundlich und entspannt in Ihre Prüfung.
Wir haben gesagt, dass es Dr. Frat hat.
Wir sind bereit mit Dr. Frat.